hi I'm mano marks developer advocate on
this is the first video in a series of
four videos designed to get you started
with the Google Maps JavaScript API at
the end of this series you will have a
fully functional google map in your app
in this series we will cover creating
your first map getting an API key
loading the Maps API and we'll walk
through the code this video will show
you how to create your first map you
will need a web browser and internet
connection and a text editor many people
use TextEdit or notepad
in this episode I'll use sublime text to
first point your browser to the Google
Maps API sample code you can do that by
clicking on the annotation here you see
a page with the map centered in
Australia click on the JavaScript plus
HTML tab and then select and copy that
code open your text editor and paste the
text now save the file somewhere as an
HTML file with the extension dot HTML
for testing purposes I'm always lazy and
save to the desktop where I know we'll
find it later then we'll click on the
file to open it in a browser you should
see your map as a tab in your browser
ok let's customize this by changing the
start location what we want to do is
change the center of the Mount and the
zoom level
first let's zoom to a latitude and
longitude pair to use you can use any
latitude longitude pair in decimal form
for this purpose I'm going to use 0 0 ok
now save and go back to the web browser
and reload the page you should see map
like this pretty much all water well
we've done is chosen a spot off the west
coast of Africa where zoom did zoomed in
too far to see anything so go back to
the text editor and change the zoom
parameter from 8 to 6 now reload the
page you'll see that you're zoomed
farther out and the Google Maps API
lower zoom levels are farther away from
the map while higher zoom levels are
closer so level 0 shows the map of the
earth fully zoomed out zoom level 19 the
fill map with streets and buildings
okay you've made your first map in the
next video I'll show you how to create
an API key using an API key enables you
to monitor your applications Maps API
usage and ensures that Google and
contact you about your application if
necessary